get the final game of today with some
Asian gambler 2300 and I play d4 for
change guess it has made amateur place
so awful so yeah queen geforce may be
the most principled move but if you play
screen c7 now i don't have any idea okay
after this move I don't have any ideas
well maybe something like this
and yeah this kind of opening is really
um difficult for four player like me who
doesn't play you for regularly so no
idea how to should I defend this pawn I
don't really mind the palm per se
getting lost but the Queen here would
have some opportunities on to maybe
switch back here on f5 h7 or something
maybe I can play something a crook h3
yet if he takes down play Bishop d3 yeah
great is also playing everything in some
place on
yeah de force of course on a problem
okay on rook g3 is playing night f5 so
this is just just stupid if I play
Bishop d3 you would place you for most
likely and then this didn't make any
sense at all yeah very unpleasant now
what can I do this doesn't really match
in any way but cannot give up deform you
can just take on c2 now
and let's this is some I guess I'm very
bad for White Queen ephors also
threatened now course I cannot allow
Queen exchange yeah well this is just a
lost position I guess maybe I shouldn't
have played before knowing that I'm not
really in top shape but ok this looks
som like something that blackened yeah
the black can just play standard moves
and just be better take care Queenie for
what do I play then most likely need to
need to one can't retreat the Queen
somewhere but this would also just lose
material yeah what can you do it's just
down just the crap position
and also of course I'm almost 22 minutes
down if it takes on default oh yeah well
maybe maybe I could okay it didn't take
okay what is the self I'm one point down
yeah the only slight hope is my bishop
Pam yeah I cannot take a lot of what the
Queen exchange can now try to get getty
fall maybe this isn't so terrible it's
of course not good but maybe the the
dark squared Bishop can do something
the only slight issue that is that he
has a cell of course the configuration
here with the king and then the Rope IAM
maybe i can get some play
try to prevent the bishop move or at
least make it them more difficult now I
got some activity for this pawn so
that's the time issue
yeah they are the opening result was
terrible at this is some I guess a
playable position it's not not lost or
something maybe can play F for now
didn't appreciate that my dear was
Bishop c4 35 for FY is a good move now I
think check time warning
hmm
above the Sun this isn't so terrible
anymore maybe it's some wow check
yeah I just hate hate it this time no
just rook c8 and this thing is gone this
position was was really a playable again
but I'm it's just an impossible to make
good news and then just stop
check why Tommy worked a long time yeah
I should have resigned earlier yeah this
was a really bad play four games of crap
played well okay let's take this um now
it's sending me some some crap messages
totally owned and so on well let's play
when I'm a bit in shape and some opening
that I actually know yeah okay let's
let's end this session I just just play
terrible okay I need to really get back
in shape for the for the five minute
games I guess 15 minutes um I think it's
halfway okay but the long time of not
playing much really didn't help for the
five-minute games okay um let's hope
it's somewhat better next time